well tonight a family is remembering a
little boy who died in a fire the blaze
broke out yesterday morning at a mobile
home park near twain and nellis victoria
saha joins us live from the scene with
an update as to what happened victoria
there's not much of what was left inside
that mobile home fire officials now
saying it was accidental three-year-old
kaiden maechum was inside the home he
died this morning i did speak with
kayden's mom rhiannon mitchum she says
her family was already dealing with
another tragedy on sunday night they
were at a candlelight vigil for the
mother of her brother's baby she says
later that night she left the lighter
torch on her dresser the next morning
she says she woke up and found herself
surrounded with flames she says she
looked at her camera and saw cayden
playing with the torch machem says she
ran out but couldn't find kaiden because
she says he was good at hiding kayden
was rushed to the hospital but he passed
away this morning kayden has two older
sisters but they were at school when the
fire happened reporting from the east
valley tonight victoria saha live local
now